we saw this article earlier where
they're making money ball or sports
analytics into a college major at
Syracuse and professor Michael viele the
Syracuse director of the sports
management department kind enough to
join us to talk about this professor
thanks for joining us explain the new
major at Syracuse this ball well good
morning Dan thanks for having me well we
tried to be visionary and
forward-thinking and about three years
ago our department set out on a mission
to figure out where did we see the
sports industry headed in the next
decade or the next quarter century and
there were two common themes that came
about one was technology and the other
one was analytics so we decided to
become the first program in the u.s. to
design a degree a four-year degree based
around sport analytics what will the
curriculum be like the type of classes
well it we've tried to actually look at
where do we see sports setting both
internationally and domestically so
we've incorporated a foreign language
component but the students are going to
take a lot of you cannot economics a lot
of math computer programming to kind of
make an analogy in sports your baseball
players they want to recruit a five-tool
baseball player we want to develop a
five-tool student so they're going to
have emphasis in math economics and
business computer programming for
language and research applications
is there anything with broadcasting
because I find most people who get into
this business as you know first hand mic
that they they still harbor hopes of
being on the air but I love this that it
allows you to have a fallback where you
get a managing degree a marketing degree
that that's going to help you a whole
lot more than wanting to be a
broadcaster well and that that's exactly
the way we've developed the degree dan
any student who walks out of a college
with those five aptitudes the ability to
understand computer programming
master a second language understand
economics computer programming be high
in math and economics
aptitude they're gonna get a job whether
it's in sports and analytics we're
working in big data and analytics or in
the business world and I really think
while all of the emphasis is on
Moneyball and player development and
analyzing players I think the business
side of sports will grow from the
analytic side as much as anything what's
the job market for sports analytics
right now people with analytics
backgrounds have a 27 percent higher job
growth than any other area any other
sector of sports so what you think about
the business side everything deals used
to be done in the golf course people
would sign a seven-figure sponsorship
deal over a round of golf it's no longer
the case everything's got to be
data-driven if a team's going to
increase its profit margin so analytics
will look at food and beverage
consumption patterns of fans it will
look at ticket buying habits of fans it
will look at sponsorship activation
profitability and return on investment
for companies that are associating their
products with sports teams so I think
the business end of this is going to be
every bit as powerful as actually
evaluating players and Syracuse has one
of the great broadcasting schools
Newhouse where you have kids who go
there they want to be broadcasters but
even with that reputation there I tell
kids all the time you know don't go into
the business for money or fame if you go
in because you love sports and you don't
mind working in a smaller market then
maybe the job is for you but what do you
tell these students who come to Syracuse
about the possibility of doing this
professionally as a broadcaster I think
to be a successful student in this
industry will eat you up and spit you
out as you know I mean it it's an
intense uber competitive profession you
have to work during everybody else's
leisure time so you're working
nights weekends and holidays and that's
not for everybody so first of all if
you're going to get into sports you have
to understand it I tell students to
follow your passion if your passion
happens to be take a guy like Matthew
Barrett who graduated from Syracuse and
Newhouse he has a broadcasting degree
but he's made a career out of fantasy
sports so if you pick a niche area and
you can focus on your passion whether
it's entertainment whether it's computer
programming and in the case of this
degree kids who love numbers who love to
sit in front of a computer and crunch
data this is going to create a career
for them and this isn't for everybody
this is going to be a very high aptitude
type of student an Ivy League caliber
student who's got great computer
programming skills but basically wants
to sit in front of a computer run
regression analysis all day and come up
with data that's then going to be turned
over to executives and team owners and
vice presidents and so forth about how
they can run a more efficient
organization Michael do you ever see a
point where we in college teach things
that help you in everyday life whether
it's real estate finances stock market
with these kids who go to college to
play basketball and they know they're
only going to be there for a
one-and-done they're majoring in being a
professional athlete do we get do we
ever have a curriculum that is sort of
geared towards the athlete who says I'm
an athlete and we can help you when you
get into that world a little bit better
than you know taking regular curriculum
it's interesting that you bring that up
we actually teach a course that most of
our student-athletes at Syracuse take
it's a course in personal and
professional development and it gets
into everything about how to manage your
own personal finances how to do basic
everyday kinds of things that we take
for granted but sometimes
student-athletes who are coming from
disadvantaged backgrounds or don't have
a good family situation they've never
been taught these basic skills about
even setting up a base
how to balance a checkbook how does how
to do your finances online those kinds
of things so we have a course that our
student-athletes enroll in that
basically is giving them the foundation
to function as a member of society I
think we need to be teaching more
classes like that yeah I do too but it's
not just you come from a you know a
tough background my kids could use this
when it comes to real estate or finance
or stocks even I mean we all can so I
think that there are things that you
could put into play in the curriculum I
just think the curriculum seems old and
tired in a lot of these universities
well that's why we've tried to be
visionary and become the first program
in the u.s. to actually offer a degree
in analytics because we think it's a
sector that's going to drive the sport
industry both from evaluating talent to
evaluating consumer behavior I mean a
perfect example was Game seven of the
NBA championship when someone went on
StubHub and paid ninety nine thousand
dollars for two courtside seats the days
of people calling the box office of a
stadium are done people are always going
to go to the secondary market and
depending what your price point is
you'll be able to find tickets for
whatever price you're willing to pay and
that's all based on analytics so whether
it's improving the efficiency of food
and beverage whether it's looking at
media returns and sponsorship activation
and so on we think we're really on the
cutting edge of some interesting aspects
of how we can prepare our students for
the next quarter century to work in this
industry Michael thanks for joining us
and good luck with the program Dan we
got to get you back to Syracuse more
often I know you're back for Coach Bay
Himes gala here in April and keep up the
great work thank you thank you Mike
that's professor Michael viele the
Syracuse director of sports management
Department the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you